burger king do you want a whopper on a
donut you might just be able to get one
because that's right Burger King bought
Canadian donut chain Tim Hortons for
eleven point four billion dollars we've
got some more info on the deal with an
estimated twenty three billion in sales
and eighteen thousand restaurants in 100
countries the new entity would be the
third biggest fast-food chain by sales
berkshire hathaway chief warren buffett
will be putting up three billion in the
deal he's going to get back preferred
stock that will pay him a dividend and
after the deal was made official burger
king stock price climbed up about
sixteen percent from its closing price
on friday tim hortons jumped about
thirty percent we've got a little more
info for you and this is where i think
it gets really interesting so in the US
companies pay up to thirty five percent
tax rate on both domestic income and
overseas sales canada levies its federal
corporate tax rate of fifteen percent
only on sales within its borders then
allows companies to pay only foreign
taxes on sales abroad if you need to
pause it for a second and reread that
this is where it kind of gets good
burger king is still going to pay the
same US taxes on its sales here but will
only you have to pay canadian taxes on
its Canadian sales Mexican taxes on its
Mexican sales and so on okay so this is
interesting because everyone said this
was about taxes and the burger king
people kind of said it wasn't about
taxes but yes it's about taxes their US
taxes are going to say the same and
everything else that they do outside of
us borders and Canadian borders will be
taxed less um I was our with Warren
Buffett though because everyone loves
this guy right everybody loves Warren
Buffett and everyone thinks he's like
the god of the markets and all that
stuff should we be a little annoyed at
mr. Buffett right now for doing this
yeah I mean I think that it's it's
obvious that this is a move to you know
mitigate tax costs for Burger King right
I mean obviously they're gonna deny it
but that's like being you know being
shocked that they're going to try to
like reduce their tax cost is like being
shocked that they're not really
concerned about the health of Americans
like it doesn't want anything Yeah right
collector whopper what LS LT probably
right the big man amazing though um yeah
so I think it's a yeah I think it's a
crappy
but Warren Buffett are you pissed at him
you know I am a big fan of Warren
Buffett's I'm not gonna lie i'm
surprised i'm really surprised and I
think it's a terrible move I mean
they're saying that corporate taxes here
at thirty-five percent and encountered
it's fifteen percent but in actuality
whatever they write off the
corporation's i think i read today that
Burger King pays twenty-seven percent
taxes on the US revenues I could be
completely wrong but this is what makes
me angry about is that you're trying to
shirt taxes your workers don't make
enough money and they're accepting a lot
of them have our own welfare your trucks
that are trucking all this food to
Canada and to Mexico even in the United
States are on a government roads and
that you're shirking your tax
responsibility yet using all the
services i think that's incredibly
short-sighted isn't that the most
American thing you can do taking
advantage of the system like in a weird
way you know I mean we had a mitt romney
a guy that was uh you know worth
hundreds of millions of dollars running
for president he was hiding money in the
cayman islands and admitted it like
openly did it and that was the best guy
the republicans could put up like our
system is so [ __ ] that like it
basically the worst you screw the system
the more you're rewarded is an extra on
it isn't that how we sort of built this
thing at this point yeah it sucks i
think that people would feel a lot less
uncomfortable about this if if the
company involved in this so-called tax
inversion were benign like apparently
walgreens attempted to do something
recently like that but then yeah but
then people boycott it and they change
their mind right but Burger King makes
people fat and diabetic you know it's
like one of those companies that like
doesn't really add anything positive to
the to the world in fact they take away
from people's health and so that's why I
don't you know I don't feel sorry for
them that they're now encircled in this
controversy that's an interesting idea
though so maybe if they were a different
business like they're in the business
fast food we know it it's the business
of it in the business just you know max
profits obviously and given us a lot of
shitty food if they maybe we're in the
business of something with a slightly
loftier goal or something you think
people would be angrier like does that
go to the business end of it or
something like that I think
we'll need to make themselves more aware
of what companies are actually doing
that I mean in a way it's a good thing
that Burger King is doing it because it
puts more of a spotlight on the whole
situation I mean if you go on the
internet you can look up several you
know tens and tens of companies that are
doing this that are in medicine or in
Tycho is a company that does that and
you know I mean I definitely think that
everyone should boycott Burger King for
sure Roy Kapur hashtag boy copper ok
sociation people do go to Burger King
then they should pay back they should
give us taxes for eating there so that
is that is not going to happen so I mean
at the end of the day is this really
about our tax system here I mean it's
our corporate tax rate just too high
like I mean if we have a country that
borders us to the north that's a pretty
decent country Canada can beat us at
this like shouldn't this really be not
about burger king but about the way our
government provide health care like for
free for its citizens yeah that's crazy
um yeah I don't mean I don't know what
the answer is I don't know you know I've
been boycotting Burger King for 20 years
because I you know choose health but
like you know um it goes back to what
you were saying before you know like in
the spirit of capitalism is it really
that you know shocking of a thing that a
company would want to like seek out its
best interests financially speaking but
I don't know so almost everything we do
here at the end of it comes down to
money in politics because you know Wall
Street bought the politicians that set
up the regulations that allow companies
to do this is that so is that really the
answer when it comes down to it like
this is just about getting money out of
politics is that the only way that you
can get politicians who will lean on
Wall Street and then once they're
leaning on Wall Street Wall Street will
force the companies to do different
practices is that it's a big one but I
just think as long as there's a
reflection of what people think to the
companies and the politicians that slow
change will come as walgreens people
boycotted that they change the minds i
think i think people really need to
choose for themselves you know like I
feel like
Americans sometimes are super lazy about
understanding the news we only go to a
new source you know on nightly
television you know if I read the news I
read The Huffington Post which doesn't
always have actual news but I also read
the guardian UK you know I mean you have
to make yourself aware and I think when
people [ __ ] about things like the
burger king a tax evasion or inversion
thing that they should vote with their
money and not eat at Burger King or not
go to Walgreens or not I really think
it's people should stop talking so much
crap about politicians and start doing
more at personal action right so
basically we just need a list you can't
eat chick-fil-a because of the gay
chicken thing you can t Burger King
because of the tax is what else
McDonald's pink slime we're gonna get to
that in a little bit give me one more
one more fast just make one up so what
Kentucky Fried Chicken what the what are
they up to again I'm sorry their necks
and they're not fully sure they could
harvest mantling them they're doing
horrible things to check